When thinking about solving this problem, we know that the insides can both be
positive numbers, so we leave them alone. We also said that they could both be
negative. Remember, a negative number equaling a negative number. But this
equation is the same one we just had. We've just multiplied both sides by
negative 1, so I don't need to solve this. The other case we had was a positive
number and a negative number. This second number or this expression could be
negative, or we could have this first number be negative, and that case this
first part would be negative. But notice, if I multiply both sides by a negative
1, this side will become positive and this side will become negative. So this is
the same equation, I don't need to solve it. Whenever we solve the absolute
value on both sides, we always write 2 equations. We keep both sides positive
and then we multiply one side by a negative. And again, it doesn't matter which
side has the negative, usually we make the second one the negative. Alright, to
wrap up this problem, what's the solution set to this absolute value equation?
Be sure to write your answer as a set.